vor wenigen tagen wurde der kamikaze
satellit wie fett in den orbit gestartet
er soll eines der größten probleme der
raumfahrt lösen weltraumschrott der
müll im orbit der erde bedroht die
raumfahrt immer mehr und könnten die
letztlich sogar unmöglich machen eine
von ihm ausgelöste kettenreaktion wäre
das ende der raumfahrt der kleine
satellit soll jetzt ausprobieren wie
weltraumschrott in zukunft verhindert
werden kann jetzt endlich zum 20
herzlich willkommen im weltraum droht
eine riesige katastrophe dass kessler
syndrom eine weltraumschrott
kettenreaktion bei der am ende nahezu
sämtliche satelliten im orbit erde
zerstört würden am schluss wären dann
so viele trümmer in der erdumlaufbahn
statt raketen gar nicht mehr gestartet
werden könnten eine schale aus
weltraumschrott rund um die erde würde
das verhindern ständig passiert dieser
größte anzunehmende unfall
es gab bereits 200 kollisionen im orbit
der erde und jeder erzeugt wieder neuen
schrott in brüssel schweren geschäft
166 millionen trümmerteile um die erde
spektakulärster unfall bisher 2009
stoßen der us-satellit nummer 33 der
willigen telefonnetzes gewicht eine
halbe tonne und der russische satellit
cosmos 2251 zusammen bei einer
aufprallgeschwindigkeit von rund 40000
kilometern bleibt von beiden satellit
nichts mehr übrig außer rund 100.000
schrottteilen sie haben jetzt die
chancen für den nächsten unfall
deutlich erhöht zum beispiel eine
kollision mit der asf der
internationalen raumstation wie hier am
2015 ein teil dieser koalition steuert
mit hoher geschwindigkeit auf die iss zu
es stammt eben vom russischen satelliten
kosmos 2251 entstand also eben bei
diesem unfall die nasa kann eine schwere
beschädigung der station nicht
ausschließen
die abfahrten werden in zwei an die hff
angedockten russischen sojus kapseln
evakuiert im fall der katastrophe
könnten wir sofort abdocken und zur
erde zurückfliegen
der weltraumschrott muss weniger werden
und deshalb wird jetzt mit dem
satelliten hieß es eine neue methode
getestet satellitenbilder aus dem orbit
zu entfernen dabei hätte die tat ein
sehr einfaches prinzip an dem kleinen
satelliten ist
ein feststoff triebwerk montiert das den
satelliten wieder zurück zur erde
bringen soll und ihm dann mit hoher
geschwindigkeit so tief in die
atmosphäre einfach und lässt dass er
vergnügt es gebe so keinen wert auf
schrott das würde zwar nicht die 166
millionen schotten aus dem orbit
entsorgen aber dafür sorgen dass es
nicht mehr werden dabei ist die technik
vergleichbar simpel und dass es extrem
wichtig der antrieb ist ein vollkommen
autonomes element das technisch
nächsten mit dem satelliten verbunden
es wird komplett autark gesteuert so
dass er selbst ausgefallenen satelliten
wieder zurück zur erde bringen kann so
dass sie vergnügen der feststoff hat
den vorteil lange lagerfähig zu sein
und so auch noch nach jahrzehnten zu
zünden wäre die ideale lösung zur
entsorgung von satelliten dieses
entsorgungs element würde einfach dazu
gekauft werden und dann am ende des
einsatzes gezündet werden also dazu
gekauft von den erbauern des satelliten
gelingt der test soll ab 2015 jeder
philipp damit ausgestattet werden sodass
die zunahme des weltraumschrott es ab
diesem datum deutlich gebremst wird
jetzt kommt es darauf an dass der
existierende schrott in zukunft effektiv
entsorgt wird wenn es dazu etwas neues
gibt dann erhalte ich euch natürlich
hier auf dem laufenden wenn nichts dazu
verpassen wollt dann durch mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den aus
die blogger hier geht es weiter mit
neues zeitalter der raumfahrt
eingeleitet neues pay sex report einfach
draufklicken und falls euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran